this is Startalk it's really a lot it
gonna tell a story about what happens
when she's in her electric car and like
testosterone Laden guys pull up next to
her in their Porsche or whatever might
be their expensive race car here it is
so it's one so what happened so the
greatest thing and this is when I have
the most fun driving is when I pull up
and I'm at the front of a stoplight and
some fancy like Porsche pulls up or some
sports car and the guy is like revving
his engine II thinks he's so cool and so
macho and he's gonna blow me away and
then an absolute dead silence I blow
their doors off it's like I'm so stealth
right it's just I'm not revving my
engine I'm just sitting there quietly
looking at them they think they're so
cool and then just gone in dense 0 to 60
and 0 to 60 so mine is 0 to 60 and 3.9
but the new Tesla's the four-wheel drive
ones the p90 D is 0 to 60 in 2.8 seconds
it's faster than the Senna McLaren f1
and it's a forty six hundred pound sedan
that seats seven people and we're
blowing the doors off of like Aston
Martin's and like you name it they can't
keep up those electric cars have a
hundred percent torque from zero are you
systematically emasculating guys one by
one yes I am doing that both at work at
the racetrack and definitely on the
street in my Tesla this is steeps order
by the way waves deep there you go okay
so thanks for that story okay mm-hmm
because for some reason guys like
associate being loud with speed instead
of sort of flip the script and in dead
silence be way faster than them
there's something more fun about it this
is Startalk